Film Courage: What thoughts do you have on
DIY release strategies?
Scott Kirkpatrick: Look…I guess the criticism
I get a lot (or the things I hear from people
all the time are) “I don’t understand
that businessey-stuff.
I don’t get the distribution stuff.
I’m going to focus on making my movie and
someone else will deal with all that.”
The truth is today, it’s never been easier
to produce a movie or any type of media content
in general.
The technology is fantastic, the costs have
dropped tremendously and anybody can do it.
The problem is that anyone can do it, there’s
tons of it.
And so it’s more important now for filmmakers
and writers to be cognizant of what is needed
in the marketplace and how that whole process
works.
And the great thing is there has never been
a better time in this industry to do it all
on their own.
Anybody can create a website, anybody can
create a blog, anybody can create a fanbase
using social media platforms.
Anybody can spit out and leak information
about their title and build up an audience
and built up an interest.
And when that magical moment, when that product
is ready to be released, already have a great
collection of people out there ready to buy
it.
And do my view on it is there has never been
as much power in the hands of individuals
and individual content creators as there has
now and I think it’s only going to increase.
So I think the ability to take a project,
an idea, from beginning to end, cheaply, effectively
with very strong results has never been more
in the hands of individual filmmakers.
So for those people who want to do their project
that is outside of the conventions of what
I talk about in Writing For The Green Light
[Scott’s book], they certainly can and they
should pursue what they want.
But if you still product within the genre
conventions that I write about you’re going
to see more traction on the professional side
because that’s going to stand out that they
were able to put a project like that together
and make a bit of profit on it for a very
cheap budget.
That’s someone who can prove to themselves,
we can bring them in and shoot films for us
or write films for us, whatever.
Film Courage: What can filmmakers learn from
the app world?
Scott Kirkpatrick: Metrics.
The incredible amount of data and metrics
that go into engineering an app and how targeted
and focused it is for a very specific audience,
I think that’s what filmmakers can take
away from the app world.
What that opens the door to is the genre conventions
that I write about in Writing For The Green
Light are good on a grand scale, but some
people want to produce a documentary that’s
focused on a touchy issue that’s only important
to a very small minority of people, that’s
fine.
We can exploit as much of that small percentage
of people as possible.
If they focus it and target it and reach out
to those people.
Same thing with faith-based content, there’s
a great audience there.
And the stuff that sometimes gets produced
on a grand scale isn’t hitting the nail
on the head the way that audience wants it,
they can do it themselves.
I think what we can learn from the app world
is how much data we have and how much of the
answers we already have in our pockets or
purses.
Film Courage: And just with the app world,
beta testing something, can a filmmaker really
do that with their movie?
Scott Kirkpatrick: It’s tough to beta test
a movie.
Beta testing I think it much better at platforms
and audience response and because of that
once you sort of make a movie, it’s sort
of one-and-done.
But it’s either going to resonate or it’s
not, so you can take as many steps as possible
for an audience to be receptive or not.
But it’s the kind of thing where you’ve
kind of got to know the audience in advance
and that’s why the assembly line distribution
works the way it does where it’s all reverse-engineering,
it starts with the audience and builds backs
to what should be produced versus producing
a movie and then hoping for the best that
it gets to the right audience.